[Musique]
salut tout le monde deuxième salve des
podcasts sur les spécialistes sont des
spécialistes on a rangé les joueurs par
rôle pour vous donner une image plus
complète de cette draft sans se
cantonner aux joueurs qui vont être
prises peuvent être pris dans la loterie
donc on a fait déjà les grands les
joueurs qui ne chute pas que je près du
cercle avec alan et là c'est au tour de
manu comment ça va ça va ça va on se
prépare à une semaine de l'échéance
on enregistre là une semaine de
l'échéance est avec toi en parler des
ball handlers puisque on te connaît
désormais tu aimes la belle passe le
beau geste à sa une
et la vision du jeu la vista donc comme
avec alan on va essayer de déterminer ce
qui existe l'existant l'état de
l'existant nvidia et puis faire des
groupes et est
donnée
aux prospects l'appartenance à tel ou
tel groupe est donc le potentiel là
dedans alors toi pour toi dans les dents
les boilers co comment tu vas les
différencier selon ce qu'ils savent
faire ou pas quel groupe tu vas tu vas
pouvoir faire en maul dans ma définition
du bonheur j'ai deux groupes donc le
porteur de balle primaire et le
secondaire très basique après dans ma
définition du primaire c'est un joueur
capable d'éliminer par le dribble et de
conserver le dribble et aussi d'éliminer
mais aussi de gist d'être gestionnaire
de l'attaqué c'est vraiment ça pour moi
de ma définition et sur le secondaire
bleus casquette voilà et pour mon
secondaire ça va être quelqu'un qui va
être capable de faire plus ou moins la
même chose mais ces caractéristiques
sont passés force première par exemple
ça va être plus un shooter vraiment
caractéristique caractérisée comme un
shooter mais qui va être capable de
2 / anp / ten phase de pouvoir faire la
gestion d'attaquant il faut qu'ils
éliminent quand même voilà un peu comme
un i bar est par exemple un exemple
comme ça sur à new york et pas forcément
pour moi un prêt mais oui mais qui est
sur certaines séquences va pouvoir être
le meneur entre guillemets des knicks -
voilà bon alors les primary donc
principalement sont des superstars même
s'il ya en nba même s'il n'ya pas que
cela
mais toi tu vas pas forcément nous
parler de potentiel superstar tu va
aussi pouvoir nous donner les en tout
cas c'est le rôle idéal en fait plus
quoi c'est plus il est basé sur leur
capacité du jeu plus que potentiel ouais
alors que leur qualité
et j'ajoute une troisième catégorie qui
peut représenter dans cette draft donc
ça va pas nous prendre beaucoup de temps
qui sont bas justement toi tu as parlé
du gars qui pouvaient éliminer et faire
la gestion du gars qui pouvaient le
faire mais un peu moins bien donc on
doute qui peut peut-être éliminés mais
un peu moins bien être gestionnaire ou
l' inverse et après il ya le les
spécialistes donc les spécialistes
peuvent être soit des joueurs vraiment
de 1 contre un pur mais incapable de
faire une gestion
alors il est en train de le devenir mais
c'est ce qui était par exemple un bones
island quand ils rentrent dans la ligne
ce genre de joueurs ou même il ya plus
longtemps les fans de new york pour
rester là-dessus alonso trir voilà des
joueurs qui sont capables d'aller scorer
balle en main mais qui vont pas trop
créer et à linverse des joueurs qui vont
pas trop que scorer mais qui vont
faire tourner la tacc et être solide en
défense évidemment si c est pour avoir
du temps de jeu en indispensable et je
vais citer un mclaughlin de minnesota
cette année et hamon alors il est
évidemment montré plus mais c'est comme
ça qu'il a été drafté au début à miami
un game veine cents ce genre de profil
donc plus de gestionnaires fac ou comme
bazot du côté de denver avec plus ou
moins de visites à la passe après ça
dépend des profils en prime mairie
donne-moi donne-moi ta liste deux
joueurs et puis après on en dise moi
j'avais catégoriser taisei washington
kentucky qu'elle ait dit chen leur
tennessee hugo besson en muse et la new
beetle jean montéro d'overtime et andrew
née marthe gonzaga
ok donc ça pour toi on dirait que ce
seront des joueurs
qui vont le mieux s'exprimer en position
de possesseur du ballon et de
gestionnaires d'attac vraiment de de
lancer le truc
ok alors dans ce dans ce groupe lesquels
sont dans le classer les plus hauts
niveaux de têtière 1 je crois que c'est
ta taille dans l'ordre c'est haïti
washington
[Musique]
besson attends je le regarde je tombais
tahiti besson et chandler qui arrive
après
après c'est neymar des monteiro ou
l'inversion keitel taille mais ils sont
d y sont déjà bas taille taille 21
besson 22
et ensuite on descend à sebha pour aller
trouver du kennedy et 28
je tenais dit ouais 28 et monteiro est
bien plus bas ouais neymar des 53 et
demande terreau
56 mais que je portais dans mon coeur
mais les choix de carrière
alors on en parlera plus tard commençons
avec le profil puisqu'on pour chacun on
va quand même présenter rapidement le
profil-type et washington dont qui est
ton premier prime eric lasser il a 20
ans il en aura 21 je sais pas si c'est
la fin de l'année au début de la
prochaine il a plus de vingt ans et demi
aussi cette année 1 92 de 0,3
d'envergure 89 kg il joua kentucky et
donc c'était un freshman mes vieux quoi
puisqu'il
qu'est-ce que tu pourquoi tu dis qui
peut gérer une attaque est pourquoi il
est tout en haut de ton classement de
ces gars là qui peuvent gérer une
attaque
badger il est très très bon pick and
roll c'est une des ses forces il est
capable aussi de tirer mi distance il
peut avoir un rôle sur en défense off et
forme attaque plutôt au nez au bol c'est
pas forcément quelqu'un qui va être à
100% dans l'obligation d'avoir la balle
donc ça j'aime beaucoup et c'est
vraiment sa gestion que c'est plus que
le pick and roll c'est vraiment un entre
guillemets 1-1 my stroke wahdat d'attac
un chef d'orchestre il sait faire les
bonnes passes et ces mois-ci 7,4 ristic
là qui me fait dire que yvette
gestionnaire d'attaquer deux pas d'une
première unité en nba
mais c'est ce flair l' aquila
offensivement qu'ils ont pour moi c'est
le meilleur d'entre eux des cinq tisco
licite et là dessus il a eu là une
variété de passes saucisses et dépasse
une main à demain et ce qu'il fait des
passes un peu fofolle ou est ce que
c'est vraiment de l'application du voile
à de la manipulation de défense comme
qu'elle passeur il est
non c'est ça c'est des passes assez
simple c'est pas trop il est assez
diversifié en termes de passe met fin à
une main demain mais il va pas tenter d
derrière le dos est pas là mais lokua
ouais c'est beaucoup moins fou fou que
ça y est plus
carré avec deux jours c'est le le voilà
le pick and roll one on one vous
regardez tahiti washington alors la
particularité manu c'est quand même
qu'il l'a il a joué peu il a joué que
deux ou trois matches meneur vraiment
meneur cette année à cannes turquie
puisque c'était ça vire wheeler kb crawl
sas et les particularités de john
calipari qui aime bien changer un peu
les joueurs de postes voilà ça les
rollers qui est plus petit et qui avait
plus la balle mais plus un joueur
d'impact au cercle et du coup d'oeil
taille était plus un shooter alors toi
tu le mets plus aussi parce que voilà et
c'est un potentiel au tir quoi
35% à 3.45 tentative par match 75 % aux
lancers francs et grosse efficacité à mi
distance pour tahiti
pour toi il sait ce que c'est ce qu'il
met aussi au dessus des autres c'est le
fait qu'il peut je peux n'est pas obligé
de se cantonner au rôle de porteur de
ballon
ouais même si en fait si la deuxième
force et ça qu'il rend ici plus ou moins
indispensables dans une équipe c'est
qu'il va pas forcément être que ce que
tu disais la catégorie 10 gestionnaire
c'est maman un peu plus que ça ouais oui
oui mais c'est pas forcément les autres
quelqu'un qui va amener du spacing mais
c'est intéressant parce que dans ce que
tu as cité finalement on pourrait
presque les classer en terme de ce pays
singh a porté
puisque t'es mis les meilleurs shooteurs
en eau quasiment
le deuxième c'est hugo besson alors ça
c'est intéressant parce que hugo besson
top 25 en a pas beaucoup qui l'ont
notamment parce que hugo besson est
davantage perçue comme un shooter
spécialistes alors toi quel rôle tu
imagines avoir en nba et pourquoi
moi je le vois meneur voit la poste un
t2 mais sur d'autres choses est ce que
j'ai appris ouais c'est vraiment c'est
un peu le contraire de taille c'est
vraiment plus un fort scoreur mais il a
un qi basket qui est assez incroyable et
c'est pour ça que le maître dont
aussitôt en finalement c'est ok il peut
shooter il est un peu voilà dans la
termes de création pour lui aux tirs
c'est vraiment vraiment intéressant mais
il va savoir aussi faire la bonne passe
le bon décalage il est vraiment une
super vision de jeu que et moi c'est ce
que c'est ce que j'adore chez les
meneurs les meneurs arrières comme ça
c'est des mecs qui vont être ok il sait
qu'il est fort sur son tir il en prend
beaucoup tes fois des mauvais mais il va
être aussi capable de voir le truc est
d'avoir plus ou moins à avoir deux temps
d'avant sur ok il va dribbler mais il va
tout de suite savoir qu'en fait si
dribbles il va faire la passe dans le
corner par exemple ce genre de choses et
c'est vraiment ça moi que c'est un peu
comme tahiti cd mais c'est un peu plus
la verse lui est meilleur scoreur que l'
aime il est vraiment très très bon
passeur aussi appelé meeting si c'est
vraiment ça le qui me fais moi le maître
aussi haut on
est ce que tu lent pour l'un comme pour
l'autre d'ailleurs comment tu vu le
l'impact défensif des deux sachant qu'il
n'est pas prévu qu'il soit très bon
comme pour surtout pour eux
non les oies les deux sont pendantes
quand pas forcément montré des qualités
défensives très très très très dingue
mais sans zhao surkin tu lis c'est
compliqué mais surtout pour comparer un
peu les deux c'est en fait comme ils
sont ils vont avoir beaucoup de
responsabilités offensivement finalement
qu'ils soient un peu à la pas des points
noirs mais qu'ils soient un peu plus
limité défensivement ça me gêne pas par
rapport au fait est ce qu'ils vont
apporter de l'autre côté du bien bon
pour la saison régulière en tout cas oui
oui après oui c'est vrai que sur sur du
play offs ils sont sélectionnés dans des
équipes qui le qui peuvent les jouer
peut-être qu'ils seront ciblés un peu
plus car peut-être qu'il pardon
totalement du temps de jeu comme
l'extrême duncan robinson cette année
avec mes amis qui a totalement disparu
tu vois mais sur une saison régulière
après je mange ou boit il ya toujours du
potentiel ya toujours un faut pas
minimiser le travail des staffs nba qui
est énorme sur certains joueurs et
brochures et d'ailleurs hugo besson et à
1,97 skin taille tout à fait honorable
donc si tu bouges bien tes pieds même si
tu es petit et frêle et il est plutôt
petit et frêle il a eu du mal
à rien qu'au combined sur les
oppositions vraiment face à des joueurs
véloces ou plus puissant mais il ya quoi
travailler moi s'il faut s'adapter aux
cimes du tout moi honnêtement le combat
et j'y tiens pas trop trop content puis
c'était la première fois qu'il avait
face à lui des joueurs un peu plus bas
laisse quand même allez y vient de pro b
est de nba c'est pas des mêmes types de
joueurs pour véloce - tout ça donc il y
aura un temps d'adaptation le chemin qui
la tue
kennedy chandler et ton troisième larron
donc le meneur lui aussi freshman
de tennessee que tu as donc en 28
kennedy chandler 1,84 donc là bien plus
petit que les deux autres mais 1,96
d'envergure c'est ce qui a rassuré lors
des mesures ou nba combined 38% à 3
points sur quasiment quatre tentatives
seulement 60 % aux lancers francs mais
plus de 50% à 2 points comment tu
quelles sont les qualités de kennedy
chandler quel meneur il peut être enfin
quel porteur de balle il peut être
aligné
moi je le vois vraiment plus la dent
pour lui ai dit le contraire des autres
vraiment uniquement basée sur le la
gestion d'attaquer le plein meeting qui
va vraiment être gestionnaire offensif
de son équipe et c'est ça va être sa
force principale c'est ça qui le fera
gagner lui fera gagner dix minutes avec
ça son potentiel défensif qui est l'un
des meilleurs pour des joueurs de son de
son poste également et il est super
rapide aussi c'est ça il peut y met de
il met plus de pression au cercle
peut-être que les deux autres
une fois il a tu as peut-être un peu
plus le cercle clé deux hôtes et puis
effectivement je suis d'accord avec toi
défensivement c'est s'est bien passé
bien plus solide c'est même bien en plus
ouais bah c'est l'une de ses forces avec
avec le play making on y trouve près je
suis ya la tech pose question mais il
faut voir ça peut pas on convainc par
exemple un gary payton qui est pas
forcément beaucoup plus grand j'ai pas
sa taille en tête mais qui si des
petites voitures tête avoir
mis la 6 2 je pense
une annonce et 1,91
donc ça fait six ans qui met le plus
mais soit c'est un joueur comme ça qui
va être capable ou je pense qu'il va
être capable de contenir les épaules 1,9
en nba c'est très très bien c'est
intéressant que tu compare à gary payton
puisque alors aux pas du tout le même
profil gary payton il n'aura jamais le
ballon et de bière on peut espérer que
kennedy le relais enfin je veux dire
avoir le ballon pour créer quoi mais
athlétiquement cani chandler c'est la
plus haute détente sèche peu de détente
tout court de nba combined ça vaut ce
que ça vaut mais c'est un joueur
explosif vers le haut et vers l'avant
aussi donc donc effectivement c'est
c'est intéressant et on aime bien
l'esprit compétiteur on rappelle quand
il perd au tournoi final et voilà il est
et dans les bras de john howard qui
connaît bien d'ailleurs
le coach adverse de michigan qui a
éliminé tennessee et voilà il est il et
il est très ému il est en très déçu
d'avoir perdu donc ça c'est généralement
positifs
après donc on descend d'un cran quand
même d'un bon cran même puisque on
arrive à en dessous même hard
le joueur de gonzaga donc qui est un
petit peu plus vieux puisqu'il a plus
d'expérience que les autres il a
également une taille à peu près correct
en 94-95 d'envergure 89 kg deux saisons
à florida de saison à gonzaga dont celle
ci which août bien mieux qu'à 38% trois
points des shoots plutôt facile 87%
lancer franc très bien
quasiment 6 passes décisives par match
même si au niveau du pourcentage de
passes décisives été plus efficaces
soient meilleurs à florida
quelles sont les forces principales
d'andrew ladd
pour moi si ça cassait sa capacité à
voir le jeu c'est vraiment ça éclairé le
jeu plus en fait c'est vraiment ça moi
qui me il m'a fait tomber un peu
amoureux de deux joueurs dans sa
jeunesse quand je les gens sur les
tournois fiba avec une canada c'est
vraiment ça qui m'a qui m'a fait écrire
sont en fait si cette capacité de pelé
meeting de vision à toujours avoir le
bon choix qui m'avait impressionné et
c'est resté avec le temps mais il n'a
pas eu le
la progression auquel je m'attendais
donc c'est comme il est toujours aussi
fort là dessus mais c'est quand même
beaucoup moins on sent que en fait en
montant de niveau lui un peu plus de mal
croyait il y domine plus autant c'est
quoi donner c'est athlétique il manque
de capacités athlétiques je vois un
free trade donc taux de lancer franc
provoqué vraiment faible que soi flo
rida
ouais c'est pas un joueur qu'un premier
pas rapide déjà et nini de dribbles
fantastiques qui va lui permettre
d'aller au cercle et il n'a pas
forcément le physique pour et le jeu
pour c'est pas d'instinct instinct il va
pas aller au cercle en pleine nuit c'est
pas son truc qui va être parce first et
voir d'un peu de tout ça mais les roches
août même si la mécanique un peu
étonnante mais c'est vraiment ça c'est
pas un attaquant
comme peut l'être justement kennedy
chandler qui est beaucoup plus portée
sur le sur le sur l' attaque du cercle
que les neymar neymar n'est vraiment
plus sur gestionnaire je pose le jeu
j'accélère quand il faut accélérer je
trouve la bonne passe
en drones m haarde qui a impressionné
lui au combat et norge cj beaucoup le
combat y met beaucoup de petit meneur
qu'on a pu observer
en face à face les uns avec les autres
je veux dire mais qui fait aussi une
bonne saison à gonzague a évidemment
facilité par l'effectif qu'il y avait
autour de lui mais les balles perdues
sont
en progression il en perd moins de moins
en moins chaque année depuis qu'il est
en nba ce qui est normal mais ce qui
n'est pas toujours le cas
ensuite nous avons gens m'ont jean
montéro alors là pour moi c'est pas du
tout le même style que les autres il
joue en overtime élite cette année avec
des joueurs plus jeunes que lui
la plupart
même si il est un des plus jeunes
joueurs de la draft ans sms mais en
overtime on peut y entrer dès 16 ans
comment décrire le jeu de jean montéro
meneur donc dominique
ouais donc utilisé par l'adie font la
découverte sur du fiba u16 shoppeuses
les amériques tacle porte le république
dominicaine et il a c'est vraiment plus
un attaquant pur avance et plus il sera
alors plus d'un wayne score bah en fait
s'il est capable de faire les deux
d'attaquer le cercle et irait donc s'est
hissé en plus sa leçon truc qu'il a des
flashs à la passe qu'il a toujours eu
mais il est vraiment plus porté sur le
scoring qui peut l'être les autres
et donc un joueur complet un joueur
rapide aussi scinder pour moi un des
joueurs les plus rapides balle en main
de cette draft très bon handle je passe
était d'accord avec moi mais moi je
trouve en dextérité
plus forte que ce qu'on a cités
jusqu'ici
ouais après s'il ya des stages chez des
chiens caractéristiques magique du mal à
évaluer sur vu ça la compétition mais
son adversité plus et c'est compliqué de
dire bah vous êtes il va être meilleur
il a sans plus sachant que c'est un
joueur qui a connu le monde
professionnel en espagne avec gran
canaria donc pour lui là ils jouent
contre des gays des gamins quoi c est
pas son niveau finalement c'est donc
c'est difficile de l'évaluer je trouve
là dessus de de dire qu'elle suivra une
caractéristique précise là il est
meilleur que les autres on est ce que la
diversité est beaucoup trop faible à mon
goût c'est le ce et c'est la raison pour
laquelle il descend chez toi ou est-ce
qu'il ya d'autres raisons plus profondes
il ya ça est un peu comme
comme les mardis l'a pas eu la
progression à laquelle je m'attendais
c'était vraiment un gars ultra
athlétique quand ils étaient jeunes qui
se rapprochait plus d'un pas le même
genre qui se rapprochait plus d'un style
allah allah et vicky voilà qui était
ultra rapide calais auxerre qui vraiment
fou td d'un camp sur phases arrêtées et
en transition quand il était vraiment
spectaculaire quand il était jeune et
c'est quelque chose qu'il il a beaucoup
moins et maintenant il est un peu plus
sur le shoot donc on n'a pas les stats
en overtime élite mais donc je sais pas
trop ce que ce que ça me donne
mais c'est c'est vraiment ça il a pas eu
là en fait il a un peu changé jeu entre
guillemets il est plus passer sur le
sur le shooting et il n'a pas forcément
conservé cette attaque du cercle trouve
sur les matches que j'ai vus en overtime
élite il va pas forcément beaucoup ils
attaquent pas trop observe trouve quand
beaucoup moins que non mais règne après
le le problème de jouer avec des joueurs
plus jeunes aussi je prends je prend
toujours la défense de jean montéro
puisque je sais moi qu'il est le plus
haut je crois
c'est qu'il ya aucun spécimen je crois
qu'il ya eu deux joueurs qui sont à plus
de 32% à 3 points sur tout le ver times
et l'iht donc effectivement les défenses
sont très resserrée donc aller au cirque
c'est compliqué ce qui peut expliquer le
nombre de trois points pris par jean
montéro
155 tentative en 23 matches 27 % c'est
faible effectivement mais il est à 76
aux lancers francs il a toujours été un
bon shooteur deux lancers-francs
d'ailleurs
le shooter pas perdu mais effectivement
il n'avait pas la tâche facile cette
année il n'a pas été très adroit mais et
106 108 thorn eux
assistent 68 eur 9 heures un ratio
correct mais vraiment sans plus là aussi
il a eu du déchet on en attendait
peut-être un peu moins
de sa part même si ça a toujours été un
joueur un peu
tu le prends avec son défaut qui est de
va perdre des ballons prendre des
mauvais tir on a bâti sa
donc donc voilà jean montéro
58e 56e bande chez manu mais je crois
que je lui ai beaucoup plus haut qu'il a
13 toi voilà donc moi j'ai 13e mais il
faut un bon contexte pour ce genre de
joueurs de façon plus que pour les
autres sans doute plus que pour kennedy
chandler ou août à washington qui ont
plus
plug partout
jean montéro voilà déjà va falloir
travailler le mental et la capacité à
s'intégrer
maintenant donc là on a fini ton groupe
1 d'accords d ce que tu appelles les
primary
de cette draft pour moi selon la
définition de oui bien sûr
maintenant seconde théorie
donc ton 2eme au
ouais donc là c'est ce que je rappelle
un peu ma définition c'est des gens qui
vont être capables de gérer de l'attak
créer
créer pour eux et pour les autres mais
c'est pas forcément leur force
principale je considère que c'est pas
l'heure france principal est que ça va
être un peu le bras droit du prime
eureko dans ce jeudi mais n'ont pas
ouais ouais vas-y on les fera
donc là moi j'avais classé paolo gontero
jeu jordan ivy dyson daniels nicolas
jovic d'haleine shérif ousmane dieng et
angie griffin
donc on a des noms qui sont plutôt vers
le vers le haut de la draft pour le coup
donc on exclut ça va être ma première
question celle de sharp pour toi c'est
un autre profil
ben c'est pas que c'est un autre profil
mais c'est j ai pensé à le mettre mais
je me suis dit enfin je me suis rappelé
des matchs que j'ai vu
et je n'ai pas vu faire ça je n'ai pas
vu créé je n'ai pas vu porter la balle
donc c'est compliqué de classe et pour
moi on l'a vu pendant la phase retour
aurait pour lui mais papa pour le voilà
on a eu les retours qu'ils pouvaient
ouais le faire meyer
je n'ai pas vu de mes yeux vu donc voilà
si c'est compliqué pour moi de le mettre
on écrit que ce convoi on croit qu'on
imagine
le le plus haut serait jayden ivy ou
bang héros c'est selon
pour chez toi ça sera banque héros qui
est juste devant avis ceci dit dans la
vente a dans sa hiérarchie
banque quéro pour toi c'est un ça peut
être un porteur de balle sur certaines
phases il va pouvoir jouer du pick and
roll etc
ouais totalement g ce qui m'a un peu
d'ailleurs déçu avec duke c'est qu'il
l'a pas suffisamment fait pour moi il
aurait dû être le point central de la
tacc de 12 cette année alors c'est lui
qui avait le plus grand taux d'usagé
néanmoins mais c'est vrai qu'on jouait
plus sûr peut-être de l'iso genre de
chose ou un one game bourque a eu
beaucoup de ballons pourquoi est-ce que
ça les années précédentes par exemple
alors que pour moi il aurait dû être pas
forcément l'option numéro une ou porter
numéro un mais vraiment être au coeur du
jeu et des actions de l'attak
jeddah ici c'est pas un prime mairie
pour toi
ça non parce que c'est pas ça selon moi
c'est pas sa force principale
en fait il va être beaucoup plus à
l'aise en
en deuxième en arrière genre en lans est
arrivé lancé en transition arrivé lancé
sur des phases a réçu rld et sur des
phases arrêtées c'est plus sa peau c'est
pas un il n'a pas l'instinct du créateur
pour les autres ouais c'est plus ça en
fait il
bon créateur il peut créer pour les
autres est passé ça y'a pas de soucis
mais pour moi il est beaucoup plus fort
en a il y en a je sais pas trop comment
dire ça file athlétique plus qu'ils ne
les créateurs et il échoue tard
puisqu'il les créateurs donc ça fait
deux caractéristiques que moi je crois
supérieur ouais
à sa création mais sur sat était plutôt
dans le sur le même
longueur d'onde que eu par exemple on
avait parlé dans le pré draft aux lf sur
les kings où il disait qu'il n'y a pas
d'incompatibilité à le faire jouer avec
un meneur comme dit aaron fox parce que
il peut être efficace à côté du ballon
donc ça c'est petit ça c'est aussi
intéressant là par exemple dans cet
exemple à ces deux mecs qui peuvent
jouer le qui peuvent eux
interférer quoi c'est qui peut mettre un
jeu un poste un jeu sur une action
l'autre portefeuille et inversement tu
peux vraiment changé sur sur un match
c'est pas forcément leur foi ça va pas
leur porter préjudice selon moi
eiji griffin alors ça du coup celle
inverse puisque c'est pas c'est un
joueur qu'on a pas on est
l'avis général classe comme un fruit ndi
qui va pas tant à voir le ballon toiture
sur ce qu'on a vu de lui paraît
peut-être au lycée tulle imagine
peut-être avoir des ballons et créer à
la fois pour lui et pour les autres
ouais aussi ouais après celle là ça va
être plus sûr du
sur comment expliques ça
si tout se passe bien
meilleur scénario xi voilà si le corps
tient si le fit est bon pour lui ça moi
je les imagine très bien faire un peu ce
que fait baptiser au tout début ce que
fait un air gai barrette par exemple
vraiment être sur des petites séquences
comme ça pouvoir monter la balle pouvoir
créer pour les autres sans que ce soit
sa force principale qui est pour moi le
tir dont actuellement comme il il a
perdu du
l'athletic commande via ses blessures
mais je moi je le vois très très bien
pouvoir
mot est un peu fort mais dépanner sur
certaines phases offensives n'ont
vraiment pas de mal à y croire après
c'est vrai bien s'il est choisi top 10
on va attendre qu'il fasse un saut sans
doute
ce que sera requis des spécialistes qui
se cantonne juste de shooter qu'ils
soient pris dans le top 10 mais si ça et
maintenant si on attend aussi en nba
actuelle que des ailiers puisque ray est
quasiment devenu aussi important que de
savoir shooter ouais en fait donc ses
jeux pap khouma il est de 0,1 non
maintenant finalement c'est devenu près
s'ils vont nulle en date ce de vous voir
un jour pouvoir faire ça alors sans
doute qu'on va n'a pas encore
enchevêtrés l'épisode sur les wings mais
sans doute qu on citera edge et griffin
aussi on pourra comparer ton point de
vue à la suite du muc
qui tu m'avais alors dyson daniels
intéressant quel joueur quel genre de
créateurs il est on en a assez peu parlé
sur envergure est pourtant là et on est
en train d'avoir à un joueur qui a une
hype top 6 7
aux états unis
ouais moi aussi un jour j'ai vraiment
aimé voir angelides cette année il a
aidé c'est pas un joueur qui est ultra
flashy mais qui est ultra important dans
une équipe donc en attaque il va savoir
faire jouer les autres il est bon en
transition il peut jouer of leon bollée
c'est pas un gamin qui va avoir besoin
de l'aval pour exister même s'il touche
pas beaucoup la balle
de par ses déplacements de par ses choix
il va y avoir un impact sur son équipe
et sa force principale pour moi c'est un
défenseur ultime c'est à dire qui peut
défendre sur les 2 1 à 3 ont oublié je
pense dès demain on voit un défenseur
d'impact sur le le point d' attaques
adverses on voit à quel point c'est
important aussi en ce moment dans les
dents les grandes joutes de playoffs en
ce moment dans les finales mais même
dans les tours d'avancis si on a ce
genre de stoppeur c'est quand même
toujours intéressant
pour pour une équipe nba qui joue les
playoffs même si bon bah s'il est choisi
top 10 6
il sera sans doute pas tout de suite
dans une équipe qui va jouer les
playoffs sur pick'n roll sur un contre
un et ce qu'il a et ce qui l'a le la
vivacité
le dribble
les contres contre nous mais discount
aux mouches je saurais pas dire en
français mais voilà les la palette
offensive pour créer de l'espace attirer
les défenses et ensuite en profiter avec
de la passe
passe le pick and roll oui après il
c'est pas le genre le plus qu'ils disent
pas le plus flashy c'est pas le tudca le
premier pas le plus explosif c'est pas
celui qui va pouvoir se créer un espace
de malades comme pouvait le faire par
exemple un trait man avec flo rida way
ses membres c'est pas sa force
principale en fait lui c'est pas un peu
à l'objet d'un et mardi veille club pour
avoir un rôle parfait et il va vraiment
répondre à ce rôle là on avec la
particularité quand même qu'il a été
remué ray je crois qu'il est vraiment
très grand
par rapport à
nous mais qu on l'admettre mais je crois
qu'il est il est plus grand que ça il
sent qu'il a 2 de 0,3 fin vraiment pour
un point moi un joueur qu avec qui on va
donner la balle ça donne aussi plus de
solutions pour expliquer bah ouais quand
tu fais de m tu ta plus d'angle de parce
que quand tu fais un mec 85 pour m il
annonça
67.5 avec chaussures
dont quoi c'est un peu plus de 2 mètres
donc dyson daniel est effectivement
énorme défenseurs et potentiellement
fluidifie catr on peut dire un peu d'
attaque c'est ce que tu disais c'est ça
fluidifie cas tout en pouvant à terme je
pense ou pourquoi pas tiré ouais à trois
points ouais il a eu un peu de mal cette
année mais il ya eu des blagues des
trucs qu'on peut se dire s'il n'est pas
ciblé offensive offensivement vraiment
défendu dur
je pense qu'il ya moyen qui sanctionne
en fait pas qui shoote à 40% sont fiche
de ça mais vraiment que si on laisse
ouvert c'est ces deux sur trois où ce
genre de tuer un autre joueur qui est
grand et petit ami d'antalis saidal
nseries qui lui aussi
plaît beaucoup pendant les work out
parce qu'il a
cette ce côté un peu hargneux voilà
cette grande gueule on a déjà parlé sur
envergure joueurs d'arizona cette année
pendant deux mois de son jeu d'alain
terry comment parce qu'il avait peu le
ballon arizona faut le dire quand moi tu
l'envisagent en nba
donc là c'est pareil c'est si tu se
passe bien pour lui je le vois vraiment
et on a eu on a observé des flashs de ça
cette saison d'un d'un mètre capable de
faire la bonne passe au bon moment de
gist de gérer son attaque sur sur
quelques minutes quand on crie ça était
absent ouais et c'est vraiment ça qui me
fait dire
ampli l'un des plus beaux arts à 20 ans
wei les jeunes rouge sophomore
normal
d'avoir si vraiment les les flashs qui
me font dire que c'est possible en fait
est que si le en bien encadré moi je le
vois bien être vraiment intéressant là
dessus c'est sa force principale c'est
puisque la défense c'est vraiment ça qui
m'a sauté aux yeux quand je les ai vus
sur sur ces deux saisons à arizona
sûrement mais capable de défendre sur
sur quasiment tout le monde sur les
extérieurs
mais sur certains trucs tu dis fait les
super bon décalage quand il faut c'est
pas sa force première qu tu ne vois
qu'il n'a pas l'instinct du meneur mois
ci même si les catégoriser chez nous
comme meneur pur race par meneur pensait
pas mon à définition du bonheur ouais il
a pas cet instinct du truc mais sur
certain moment tu dis ok belle passe sur
du sur des sur des coeurs sur des
backdoors sûrs sur un peu de pick and
roll a d'ailleurs
d'ailleurs toujours un peu plus quoi
ouais
3,9 passes décisives pour seulement
1,4 turnover c'est mieux que la plupart
des joueurs qu'on a cités jusqu'ici en
termes de ratio ans un joueur prend soin
du ballon aussi qu'il va faire des
quasiment quatre passes décisives alors
certes arizona un système qui favorise
voilà le mouvement de ballons tout le
monde s est révélé voilà tout le monde
s'est un peu shooté tout le monde c'est
couper tout le monde sait dribbler donc
c'est plus facile de faire quatre passes
décisives dans ce système là quelqu'un
tue qui mais
effectivement ça reste quand même un
joueur efficace et qui a montré voilà
36% à 3 points cette saison alors pas
sur un gros volume et des lancers francs
qui progresse de m 0,4 avec 2,13
d'envergure
peut-être un peut-être un style s'il
tombe en dehors du top 15 20 ça peut
être un des styles ci se développe comme
comme tu me vois dans le meilleur
scénario de de cette cuvée il nous
manque qui
nous ment qui veut bien guillaume beach
à aller on parle français d'abord
ousmane
zhang
alors ça c'est
là on est vraiment sur un profil hyper
hyper particulier hyper voilà
risques et
ousmane de mai de 0,7 mais de mettre 0,7
mais paradoxalement
pour toi c'est un bol rendler même
secondaire
le voit plus secondaire parce que
basquiat l'insep c'est lui qui portait
la balle tout le temps si c'était
vraiment lui le
l'option numéro une fin qui gérait les
offensives
et sur le ring biel on l'a vu petit à
petit prendre un peu plus de confiance
et justement montrer qu'il est toujours
capable de le faire et il est capable de
bien le faire on sait c'est vraiment ça
qui
qui me fait dire qui peut sur deux sur
certaines phases être un
voilà gérer une attaque qui a retrouvé
la bonne passe et ce qui pas l'éliminer
quand même
pour aller aussi recueillir way pour
aller au cirque
c'est
moi pour moi non pour certains oui il a
il a vraiment du mal à aller vers le
aller au cercle et surtout terminer au
cercle c'est pal pour moi sa force
première mais il peut shooter
donc en soi ça me dérange pas trop que
s'il est secondaire
ça me dérange pas trop que ce soit
quelqu'un d'autre qui fausserait goto
games ouais mais va falloir qui shoote
pour toi pour avoir ce vrai rôle en nba
pour qu'on puisse exploiter ses vraies
qualités sinon ça va être compliqué
ouais faut qu'il fasse plus que plus que
du plein meeting parce que pour moi rien
que maintenant le pli meeting est pas
encore au top niveau
il a une marge de progression là dessus
qui est inévitable sur le tire aussi et
il ya une face à lille facilité de deux
dribbles de conserver la balle de
navigation balle qui est vraiment
intéressant tout seul donc ce ce to me
fait dire qu'il peut le faire c'est pas
le mec le plus dur du monde
mais moi je sais lire tu pas forcément
très très fan du joueur mais le
potentiel est indéniable
absolument de m 07 je sais porter la
balle je sais shooter ça ne se trouve
pas partout la rareté fait aussi le
profil et c'est pour ça qu'il est prêt
prévu pour être le premier français dont
le nom sera prononcée par adam silver
6,7 au premier tour théoriquement c'est
ce qui sait ce qui nous attend du côté
de semaine ding c'est pour ce potentiel
et grâce à cette deuxième partie de
saison surtout en nba même si tu l'a
rappelé ça reste un projet
contrairement way
en tout cas moins que nicolas jovovich
alors là tu m'intéresse parce que pour
moi nicolas jovovich si tu lis je lève
sûrs mais si tu lis et les scouting
report us qui lui sont consacrés on
parle beaucoup de ça sont frontières qui
est son sa carte de visite
[Musique]
je fais de m je peux le
10/10/10 de glisse et lille a grandi du
coup je mets dedans je filoche tout va
ça c'est la carte de visite nicolas
jovovich qui jouait donc oméga mozart
c'était cette année
pour toi il peut être un porteur
secondaire parle-moi de ses autres
qualités j'ai parlé du tir
ouais tout allemand s'est cassé un mec
de 2,10 qui équipa le plus rapide du
monde avec balle en main mais qui peut
qui peut dribbler qui peut éliminer en
europe sur certains matchs en main à mes
gars moi je les fûts limin aider des
gens est allé au cercle est terminé et
j'ai surtout vu faire des passes qu'un
mec de 2,10 lambda ne sait pas faire
quoi donc
c'est vraiment ça qui m'a interpellé moi
quand j'ai vu juste c'est au début je
l'avais classés 5 dans les 50 50 60 et
je me suis fait jouer tous les matches
disposent sur youtube de cette saison
et je me suis dit oh non c'est pas
possible de en fait ils faire ce qu'il
fait à 2,10 pas normal entre on
est sûrs en plus de cette capacité à
pouvoir passer à pouvoir aller au cercle
il peut chuter il est à 35 % à froid à
trois points quelque chose comme ça
c'est avec un vrai ça paraissait
tentatives
par match à trois points ce qui est
complètement dingue
et ils essaient des shoots pas toujours
simple simple quoi c'est vraiment un
gars qu'est labellisé là bas c'est
quelqu'un qui est connu donc il est
défendu c'est vraiment quand il va
shooter créer un vrai espace cellule a
dû catch and shoot il ya
et il ya cette fameuse instinct de
passer très serbe peut dire vrai et il a
que 19 ans
et 3 2 saisons pros dans les jambes
ouais c'est ça est ce que ma un certain
niveau jeu évidemment ces comparaisons
faciles parce que des européens et tout
mais
est ce qui peut être une sorte de bojan
bogdanovic en plus grand qui a montré
aussi qu'ils pouvaient faire du
secondaire louis balling du porteur de
balle secondes
après beaucoup d'années quand même pire
améliora joutes à bagdad un beau jeune
abois yann par abriel je connais un peu
moins du coup mais c'est aussi un très
bon enfin probablement shooter supérieur
jovovich
pourquoi pas fraîche du coup j ai pas
trop trop vu ouais c'est difficile de
même une pareille défensivement c'est
comment nicolas jovic
c'est pas sa force principale on va
s'entendre là-dessus mais moi je les ai
vus être quand il veut vraiment être
intéressant en défense et pas uniquement
sur les big moi je les ai vus sur
certains matches aller prendre le meneur
adverse
et lui dire non non tu passeras pas qu'à
mince et en face à même d wade des
petits américains qui sont assez rapides
comme on peut connaître en europe
bagis laissait pas faire le le gamin
donc magie et mais ce qui me dérange un
peu je te vas trouver un point négatif
c'est que c'est pas forcément 100% comme
ça c'est des fois il s'en fout un peu et
ouais il a des mouvements d'humeur aussi
très serbe et du coup c'est pas la ligue
adriatique au sinon ouais ouais mais sur
certains moments je me moi je les vues
et hockey très intéressant défense a
pris va voir ce qu'il va faire face à
des mecs
oui totalement différent bien sûr
autrement plus d'avoir même et c'est ça
peut être intéressant pour défendre sur
de l'ailier voilà pas forcément des
meneurs mais
ça peut être intéressant dans tout cas
c'était
vraiment vraiment malin de le mettre
dans les séquences d'harry parce que
c'est pas quelque chose qu'on fait
généralement
mais si l'équipe nba qui le draft qui
pensent peut-être qu'il peut être
choisie plus haut que ce qu'il est
projeté en tout cas parce que parce
qu'un joueur comme tu le décris ça peut
ça peut aller dans la loterie à 19 ans
ouais là il annoncé 20 25 vous avait
annoncé fin de première
presque pareil
cdc d1 c'est un joueur qui a un contexte
favorable outreman ça peut être vite
très compliqué que moi ou c'est plus ou
moins quelqu'un qui a été habitué enfin
j'ai pas gelé pas trop trop violent
jeunes jeunes donc sur du bus et du 18
mai s'est très vite quelqu'un qui a été
labellisé donc a été plus ou moins
qu'aucun et
donc à voir comment il va il peut réagir
à voir s'il ya que des assiettes
quelqu'un qui est pas forcément européen
donc une culture ça peut pas avoir un
choc aussi tu y vas denver par exemple
quasiment le film parfait oui parce
qu'il ya du serbe parce qu'il ya de
l'européen parce que ça joue très très
bien parce que le staff et l'équipe
aussi très très très bon mais s'il va
par exemple à charlotte où c'est
vraiment beaucoup plus transition je vis
très américanisée là je ne sais pas
il ya des gens sur son poste à charlotte
d'autres qualités ou jeudi charlotte
quand je prouvais
moreland aux deux questions de personne
que tu as pas forcément misé d'antalis
trésor qu'ils malakai branham qui sont
tous les deux dans le pré vu dans le top
25 chez envergure branham 19 prévoient
qu'ils 22e deux joueurs alors aux
gabarits différents mais mais pareil des
grands une sorte d sorte de grand
arrière pour toile et on va les faire
évoluer dans d'autres rôles très forts
qu'ils en 93 pour cent kilos ce buffle
et macadam
1,99 pour 82 kg mais de 12 dans
ces deux joueurs que j'apprécie que j'ai
assez haut d'ailleurs dans mon dos monde
bande par rapport aux autres surtout
qu'ils les quatorze mois
mais c'est pour être alors qu'il s'est
vraiment le plus trendy
féroce quoi donc est une sorte de smart
mais en moins bon
organisateur quoi ouais mais meilleur
shooteur que smart ah ouais quand ta
façon
je sais c'est vraiment ça qui me mois
les livres c'est vraiment un
joueur qu aura un rôle mais qui va être
très très bon il va être plus plus à
chaque fois quoi ici site où tout est
bien un briquet c'est tu l'a rappelé et
un gabarit quand même assez dingue qui
va pour moi le potentiel défensif
incroyable qui va pouvoir défendre sur
quasiment tout le monde / / / des
séquences way qui prend assez sain
buffles et qui shoote il a au dessus il
a en fait c'est un peu l'inversé d'un
griffin cas où cela la cour va être un
peu elles se croisent entre les deux
joueurs parce que du coup il prenait sa
place à griffin au tout début qui joue
beaucoup moins et avec le temps griffin
a gagné 10 minutes que qu'il a perdu
mais c'est vrai qu'au dont c'est pas
évident ce que tu dis 1 31%
67 oh lancé c'est pas fou
non mais y'a dit il ya des trucs
surtout anti crise et surtout en début
de saison où il était incroyable et
après comme il a un peu perdu des
vitesses de fait un peu mon temps de jeu
même s'il a trente minutes de moyenne il
avait un comme guy finn a trimé explosé
on s'attendait pas à ce qu'il vienne
aussi rapidement très très bon
avec ses blessures du coup il a perdu un
peu de
oued influence d'un flux ans dans le jeu
quoi donc en plus bancaire on est
devenus très très bon mark williams est
devenu très très bon wendell moore
progresser dans un rôle kuduro quel on
l'attendait pas trop d'intérêt beaucoup
plus de ballons aussi mais je m'agite
croit fortement et c'est pour ça que je
les 14 de part son tir et sa défense
pour moi c'est ruines 10 ultime
malakai branham qui lui a des stats au
tir folle 1 53% à 2 points 41 à 3
41,6 et 83 aux lancers francs même si le
volume à trois points est faible n'est
que 2 8 par match pour toi c'est un
joueur qu'on va cantonner à son shooting
qu'on va faire jouer un peu à la rip
hamilton of bol c'est pour ça que tu l'a
pas mis dans tes beaux lenders
way plus j'aime bien la comparaison
d'ailleurs mais et mais c'est un genre
que j'ai assez apprécié rapidement dans
la saison et je suis allé voir un peu du
film my school
et j'ai vu que
henry school contrairement à son rôle à
hawaï aux states yportais énormément la
balle
donc gelé pas mis parce que cette année
on n'a pas trop trop viril alep à
auxerre mais même quand il l'avait
saisie sans que l'une cherche
donc est ce que c'est parce que le
niveau est devenu un peu plus haut et du
couffo keith maintenant pour avoir un
rôle et les minutes qui se spécialise
qui viennent élite sur du tir sur lequel
était très très bon
ou sur ce petit séquence pouvoir encore
garder le point gérer là une attaque je
sais pas il faut voir comment il répond
à la diversité
ça va prendre du développement prendre
après peut-être que le spacing aussi
peut l'aider
un terrain plus grand des faux voire
plus de puissance aussi peut-être sur le
web sous l'eau du corps même sur du
premier pas
après je je sais qu'il peut le faire
ouais enfin qu'il là qu'il l'a fait
après c'est un tout autre niveau
donc à voir et pour conclure alors je
vais quand même citer pour pas fâché
hugues deren sidron qui était un bol on
leur
en entier
c'est vrai c'est un beau landler caleb
aux coupes au cercle
plus scoreur que passeur mais mais c'est
lui qui avait le ballon en main en tout
cas du côté de m6 state et pour rajouter
l'oncle le le le troisième échelon celui
des gestionnaires donc ça va être plus
des joueurs qu'on va aller target au
second tour j'ai fait plusieurs articles
sur alan doss williams le meneur de wake
forest qui pour moi
un des meilleurs passeurs
techniquement de cette draft
dépasse mains faibles une main dans la
course
cornet reposer laser fin trait et passe
très très difficile à exécuter
vraie connexion avec jake larabia que
j'aime de tout mon coeur et qui va être
drafté
malheureusement à lempdes milhas ne joue
qu'à 28% à 3 points et 60 10 aux lancers
francs en carrière ce qui n'est pas
terrible
puisque généralement quand même les
joueurs qui parviennent à se faire un
trou en tant qu'organisateur comme ça
ces joueurs qui sont bons shooteurs en
jeu c'était cité gates vincenzi citait
jac orie mclaughlin du côté de jordan
mclaughlin du côté de de minnesota ce
sont des joueurs qui ont des 35 36 voire
mieux à 3 points donc faire progresser
là dessus pour alan doss williams mais
c'est un joueur qui va très facilement
au cercle qui provoque beaucoup de
fautes aussi
de par ses drones de quoi bah ouais de
par sa puissance et ses plus c'est
vraiment plus en puissance et en
en
acceptation du contact donc c'est un
joueur très atypique assez intéressant
qui vaut peut-être le pari en tout cas
dans une deuxième partie de draft
j'avais également il y en a pas d y en a
pas des caisses en calling il est si le
meneur très expérimenté de villanova qui
bakic un très très très très très bon
shooteur montrait très bon lui à
linverse de à lempdes 41% à 3 points
alors qu'il est défendu de près on le
connaît c'était sa cinquième saison m6
et sur cette tentative à trois points
par match 90 % aux lancers francs
mais seulement 46% à 2 points voilà au
cercle il un peu de mal mais mine de
rien 1 90 et pas ridicule on a des
joueurs nba qui font à 90 il a pris du
il a pris du gab il est pour moi il est
n bière est dit sur le gabarit et sur le
tir et sur le le processus voilà c'est
un joueur qui vient de villanova on les
connaît mieux les joueurs de villanova
c'est solide dans le ce que tu me ce que
tu me dis moi ça me fait direct pensez à
bien leur ronson
moins fort en un contre un jon ronson
est si puissant ouais mais
c'était un peu un gestionnaire mais il
savait savait faire la bonne passe il
était très bon shooteur absolument y est
petit mais jen brunson des plus petits
et a contrario pouvait poster son joueur
il ya toujours eu ce côté je vais me
créer mon tir en créant un peu là elle
était très temps qu'est un ouais encore
oui oui mais guy les psys moins ça plus
un shooter un peu traditionnelle et
parmi les styles et je finirai avec lui
il style qu'on pouvait repérer en
observant que les statistiques puisque
on n'avait pas à les regarder les matchs
de vanderbilt
qui sont toujours une purge scottie
pippen junior fils de
seulement 1 m 87 mais en 97 d'envergure
je trouve très bon défenseur je trouve
énormément de progression dans
l'appréhension collective du jeu et
des pourcentages en progression alors ça
se voit pas à trois points il a baissé
mais la difficulté moyenne de son tir il
était vraiment seul à gérer la taxe
cette année elle a largement augmenté
avec puis aux lancers francs il est à 76
% car ce n'est pas extraordinaire mais
c'est correct et et moi j'aime bien
scottie pippen junior en paris pas cher
entre 40 et 60 tu as besoin d'un meneur
pour gérer la deuxième unité au pire tu
lui donnes que des missions défensives
et tu fais gérer sa part un gars un peu
plus grands un peu plus expérimenté lui
il a le droit à quelques rep puisqu'il
est que junior il n'est pas très pas si
vieux que ça et au mieux tu as un joueur
qui tout de suite voilà apporte du liant
et capable de défendre donc
potentiellement capable de jouer en
playoffs
et et le jackpot c'est bien sûr si le
tir rentrer mais voilà après gary payton
le deuxième scottie pippen junior
pourquoi pas
manu est ce que tu as une wild card à me
jouer ou pas
là comme ça non
qui sera le qui sera le meilleur de thé
primary en termes de shoot on avait donc
kennedy
hugo taye taiwo shoot besson besson ok
tu parles du tir
mais son hockey hulot besson et bien
voilà qui va un podcast qui va remonter
le moral de ses fans
puisque tu l'as tu l'as dans mon top 30
et bel argumentaire pour le voir donc
avec le ballon en main plus que dans un
rôle de shooteur même si ses shoots et
non en nba merci manu on se merci à toi
reste ensemble évidemment jusqu'à la
draft et on arrive pour l'épisode le
dernier de la série de trois ce sera sur
les wings les ailiers de cette draft
avec voilà plusieurs catégories the
wings et hugues qui nous donnera ses
classements personnel à bientôt tout le
monde on vous fait des bisous abonnez
vous mettez nous des bonnes notes ciao
ciao ciao